okay so today's video is on a process
called homeostasis it's the balance that
our body maintains internally so let's
go ahead and get started here's kind of
an analogy of homeostasis in your home
here's the floorplan of someone's home
and usually centrally located on the
wall of your home is is a thermostat
which helps to control the temperature
inside your home and maybe tucked away
in the back of the utility room is the
furnace well connected to the furnace
are all the heating and air-conditioning
vents and the thermos the thermostat and
the thermostat and the furnace are
connected to one another by a wire well
let's say that you have the temperature
in your home set for 30 set for 77
degrees Fahrenheit but because it's a
really cold day outside maybe the
windows are open it's only 74 degrees
inside so the thermostat will turn on
and send a signal to the furnace the
furnace will respond by producing heat
that heat will be poured and pumped out
of all the heating vents until
eventually your home begins to warm back
up 75 76 77 degrees at that point the
thermostat won't stop sending a signal
to the furnace the furnace will stop
producing heat because the home is back
to normal the great little analogy of
homeostasis
well homeostasis then is the process
where the body maintains a constant
internal environment the reason this is
so important is because of all the
internal chemical reactions that are
proceeding right now in order to keep
you alive the chemical reactions that
are happening right now for instance you
know they all take place in a 98.6
degrees or a 37 degrees celsius body and
if our body temperature gets too high or
too low many of those internal chemical
reactions do not proceed as effectively
or as efficiently as they should and so
we have control systems in place to
adjust our bodies whenever a change is
occurring so besides temperature which
is probably the one that everybody knows
other things that are controlled
besides temperature would be for
instance our blood
sugar our blood Sugar's percentage is
about 0.1% of our blood sugar and if
that gets too high or too low we can
suffer side effects same with blood pH a
pH of seven point three five if our
blood pH gets too high or too low we can
suffer side effects as a result of that
so a moment ago I mentioned that the
body has control systems to to cause
change and well what are these control
systems well we can break it down into a
few categories control systems are made
up of sensors or receptors receptors
gather information about the body and
the environment in this case there are
thermo receptors in the woman's hand
that are gathering information about the
candle that she's getting too close to
so heat is being detected by the thermal
receptors in the woman's hand well then
we have what's called the communication
system and it's a series of nerves where
messages will be sent throughout the
body so the nervous system is part of
your communication system and in this
case an electrical signal called an
impulse is going to travel from the
woman's hand from the sensors in the
woman's hand up to her brain well
they're going to the brain because the
brain is what we call our control center
receives information from all the
sensors receives information from the
eyes from the nose from the hands from
the feet from the tongue and ultimately
this is the brain the brain is our
control center it receives the impulse
from the woman's hand in this case well
finally the brain has to tell the body
to change its action and so the brain is
gonna send a signal to what's called the
target in this case the target is the
woman's hand you know if she was
stepping on something sharp the target
would be her foot but in this case she's
touching something hot so the brain is
sending a signal back to the woman's
hand that will cause her muscles to
stretch and contract very abruptly and
perhaps even shout out a few colorful
words but all these control systems here
are designed to maintain a constant
eternal environment and one of the
trademarks of homeostasis is what is
called negative feedback this is what
regulates most of the body whenever a
change is occurring and it's the process
where your body will reverse a change
that is happening you know in this
animation here this child's been stuck
outside in the cold temperature and 98.6
degrees is our normal body temperature
and as the temperature as your body
temperature drops and this child gets
colder and colder and colder eventually
they're gonna get so cold where their
body begins to shake or shiver
well shaking and shivering is designed
to generate heat when your muscles
stretch and contract rapidly and
violently as they do in shivering they
rub on one another and that generates
heat and that eventually will warm you
back up notice how that's an example of
negative feedback the change that was
happening is that the kid was getting
too cold but negative feedback reversed
the change and warmed him up well the
opposite of true is true also if you're
at the beach too long and you're outside
in the hot Sun notice how the woman's
body temperature is beginning to rise
eventually if the body temperature gets
too high she'll produce little droplets
of sweat all over the body well how does
this actually cool you down how does
sweating actually cool you down when the
sweat evaporates it takes heat away from
the body and as more and more and more
sweat is produced and evaporated more
and more and more heat is taken away
from the body eventually you get back to
normal great examples again of negative
feedback because your body worked to
fight the change and reverse the change
to get you back to normal so another
great example of negative feedback is
what happens when you hold your breath
you know if you hold your breath carbon
dioxide begins to accumulate in your
blood because you're holding it and
you're not getting rid of it well when
that happens your brain is alerted that
there's too much carbon dioxide in your
blood and your brains are gonna respond
to that your brain will send out
hormones through your blood the hormones
are gonna
to the muscles of your diaphragm your
diaphragm is the muscle in between your
ribs that helps you breathe and when
you're when you're your diaphragm
receives these hormones from the brain
the diaphragm is gonna relaxed forcing
you to inhale and that exhale you can
only hold your breath for so long
eventually negative feedback is going to
cause you to take breaths again well if
there's a process called negative
feedback that's probably going to be the
opposite something called positive
feedback and this is a process where
your body doesn't stop the change your
body will actually encourage or promote
the change that's happening and so this
is important when a rapid change is
needed one of the best examples of this
happens when a woman's about to give
birth and she starts to experience
pregnancy contractions contractions are
when muscles in the uterus begin to
stretch and contract ultimately trying
to push the child out trying to give
birth trying to deliver the child well
what happens is there's a nerve in the
cervix that will send a signal to the
brain the brain will receive that signal
and we'll send hormones all throughout
the body the name of this hormone is
called oxytocin and so ask yourself well
if this was negative feedback if this
was negative feedback what would happen
next well if this was negative feedback
the body would try to reverse and stop
those contractions but if that happened
the baby would never be delivered so
negative feedback is not the proper
solution in this example the body is
going to respond with what's called
positive feedback positive feedback
encourages the change those hormone that
hormone called oxytocin actually helps
to speed up and encourage the muscle
contractions that way the child will be
born even sooner so the process of
homeostasis it's really a team effort
there's a lot of body parts and body
systems working together that's the
point of this slide I want to briefly go
over what's called thermo regulation
thermo is a prefix that means heat or
temperature so this is the process of
specifically maintaining your
body temperature well you have nerves
you have sensors in your skin to detect
whether or not you're hot or cold in
this case we're gonna detect cold that
the person is cold and so the nervous
system is then next gonna be used
because the nerves in the skin are gonna
send an electrical signal to the brain
through the nerves to the brain that
requires the use of the nervous system
your brain is then gonna respond by
sending out chemical hormones into the
blood and hormones are all part of your
hormones and glands are part of your
endocrine system so now your endocrine
system is involved those hormones are
going to be received by the muscles of
your body so now we're including the
muscular system and ultimately it's the
muscles that are going to begin to shake
and shiver ultimately causing you to
warm up a great example what I mean by
your body works together that there's a
lot of cooperation between body parts
well ever now and then our body will
experience disruptions to our normal
levels of fluids and temperatures so
homeostasis can become disrupted you
know most of the disruptions are
temporary we've all had infections and
fevers and sore throats and you know in
the picture if you do enough pull-ups
sure you're gonna have muscle soreness a
little bit later in the day or the next
day you know these are all fairly
temporary you know we've all had
infections where we've you know had
fevers and we've had you just you know
lay in bed for a couple of days
eventually our immune system fights off
the infection and we feel better we're
not all homeostatic disruption is
temporary sometimes it's permanent
there's two examples of frostbite you
know this person I don't know if it's
the same person or not but the person's
hand and the person's fingers in this
example they clearly were exposed to
cold for too long and you can see that
the the cells of the toes are beginning
to turn black they're dying and
ultimately the sensors and the toes
aren't gonna work anymore the cells are
dead they're not going to be able to
send or receive signals from the brain
so homeostasis is going to be disrupted
simply because there
no communication between the toes and
the fingers that you also see and often
we can even see major disruption and it
would lead to hurt paralysis this is
where messages from the brain never
reached the target
you know normally the brain will send a
signal from the brain down to let's say
the feet allowing you to walk or move or
kick a soccer ball or move up steps you
know that's how it's normally supposed
to happen but if there's some kind of
injury let's say the at the X location
this person had had a broken spine as
the result of a kind of an automobile
accident the brain can still send a
message down to the person's foot the
problem is the the message never gets to
the foot it never gets past the injured
site so this is an example of a person
who would be a paraplegic they wouldn't
be able to move below their waist so
even though you can put a ice cube on
their on their foot the this the signal
never gets to the brain or the brain can
try to send a signal to the foot saying
you know wiggle the toes but the toes
never receive that signal and this is an
example of being a paraplegic if the
injury is higher on the spine this could
be a lot more devastating the brain can
send a message but it never again gets
past the injury site in this case the
person could be a quadriplegic where
quad means four they don't have the use
of their four limbs two arms and two
legs and so again this is a more severe
injury in that the person has less use
of their body but great example of
homeostasis disruption because signals
are not being sent there's no
communication below the injury site you
know sadly today one of the growing
causes of homeostasis disruption is the
disease diabetes well before we go to
diabetes let's kind of discuss how the
process is supposed to work in a normal
healthy person so here's a bunch of
cells and cell
the glucose glucose is the food if a
fuel that sells are gonna take in and so
the mitochondria will use the glucose to
make ATP which is an energy molecule and
so after meals the amount of glucose
begins to rise in our blood and so we
see a bunch of G's have just popped up
these this is the glucose that's risen
in the person's blood and when the blood
sugar the blood glucose gets too high
and alert is sent to the brain so the
problem lies in those little doorways
those little blue channels that you see
that are remain that are in the closed
position right now when the brain
receives the alert that the blood sugar
is too high the brain is gonna send a
signal to your pancreas the pancreas
will then release a hormone called
insulin into your blood the insulin will
attach itself to these little channels
these little doorways and the insulin
kind of acts like a key the insulin will
cause those channels to open so now that
the channels have received insulin the
channels begin to open one by one they
begin to open and I hope you see what
this is gonna allow this is gonna allow
the glucose to enter the the cells
glucose would diffuse from the high
concentration in the blood to the low
concentration in the cells and there we
see the glucose moving from high
concentration in the blood to the low
concentration in the cells giving the
blood scuse me given the cells
much-needed nutrition and lowering the
amount of glucose back down to its
normal level well especially here in the
United States we have a growing problem
with type 2 diabetes but diabetes in
general type 1 type 2 diabetes has a few
things in common
first of all cells need glucose because
like I said a moment ago the
mitochondria are gonna use that glucose
to make their energy in the form of ATP
so anytime you have a meal glucose
begins to rise in the bloodstream
and as we see glucose rising a person
must have just had a meal and so like we
saw a moment ago now that this person
has elevated blood sugar there's an
alert that will be sent to the brain and
just like the last time those channels
those doorways are in the closed
position so your brain will receive an
alert that the blood sugar is too high
and the brain will send a signal to the
pancreas now depending on what type of
diabetes you have type 1 or type 2 what
I'm gonna say for now is that a damaged
pancreas will often release too little
insulin and so here you see just a small
amount of insulin being released and a
couple cells a couple of channels
receive insulin and so a few channels in
my animation can at least open
well that that'll help to take in some
of the glucose from the blood just not
enough so now that a few of the channels
have opened at least a little bit of
glucose can diffuse from the blood into
the cells but not enough to bring the
level back down to normal and so the
glucose no and that's the problem is
that the glucose level in the blood
never returns to normal and so as the
hours go by eventually a person's gonna
have another meal which is gonna add
even more glucose to the already high
amount of blood sugar and so hair hair
you see hours have just gone by and a
bunch more g4 glucose is being added to
the person's blood now we have a really
major alert going to the brain too much
blood sugar but again the pancreas is
just not releasing enough insulin to
open these channels and so ultimately
the cells begin to starve I should say
ironically the cells begin to starve
ironically because there's food on the
other side of the channel
there's glucose which is food for the
cells but ironically the cells begin to
starve because they just
can't get the glucose and as the glucose
level rises and Rises and Rises that
alters the pH of blood sugar the blood
sugar becomes acidic normal pH is around
7.35 a very weak base but when the
amount of glucose begins to increase it
goes into the acidic range and these are
some of the negative health effects of a
lifetime of diabetes so one of the ways
that of course we can try to combat
diabetes is through proper exercise and
proper diet now if you're an if you are
a diabetic there is a form of treatment
so when it comes to the treatment of
diabetes you know if a person's pancreas
is not producing enough insulin
well then let's provide insulin for that
patient they can take at home insulin
injections or they literally inject
themselves with a needle and inject
insulin directly into their blood that
will allow those channels to then open
and one by one when the channel is open
the high amount of glucose that's in the
person's blood can diffuse into the
cells and over time the blood sugar
comes back down to normal so there you
go I hope you have a good solid
understanding of what homeostasis is all
about if you're in my biology class you
know try to answer these questions on a
separate sheet of paper I'd be happy to
check your answer is either before
school or after school for accuracy so
go ahead and try these for review and
let's see how you do good luck